our series of more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we're going to introduce you to
a group of former high school students
who started a life change in support
group or a friend who was battling
cancer now they are taking that effort
launched in a garage
19 years ago nationwide vladimir
duthiers shows us where it all began in
Scotch Plains New Jersey dad can't wait
to hear in the morning to you good
morning Gail this is an amazing story
so when rob Matar was diagnosed with
cancer at 17 years old his friends
rallied to support him that was back in
2001 now the same close-knit circle of
friends is inspiring high school
students across the country to join in
the fight against cancer it all started
here in this New Jersey garage nearly
two decades ago so this is the garage
where that picture was taken and this is
where it all went down this spot the
spot where a group of high school
juniors rallied around their friend Rob
Matar as he was going through
chemotherapy for testicular cancer I
remember coming home from from baseball
practice there were that you know 15
friends here and Rob's mom had reached
out to us beforehand just to say that
Rob was starting to lose his hair and he
was doing really self-conscious about it
so the group came up with a plan to
shave their heads to match their friend
so people were like are you doing it and
the next guys like yes I'm in and then
they do it and then the next person's
like to me next and it just built this
momentum and they took that momentum and
started the club at their high school
with more than 200 people showing up to
the first student movement against
cancer or smack meeting the club held
events and provided emotional support to
students affected by cancer my senior
year they had raised more than one
hundred thousand dollars through
fundraisers it made me feel great that
immediate support helped me get through
that stage but omits Rob's diagnosis his
father was battling widespread cancer I
actually had chemotherapy sitting next
to my father
chemotherapy sitting next to your dad
yeah it makes you feel better in a way
about getting chemo fair
therapy because you're with your father
and you have that natural bond of well
this is terrible but we actually laughed
about it while Rob recovered his father
did not he died
Rob's freshman year of college my
thoughts drifted to your mom who would
have watched her husband and then her
son dealing with these inter mountable
challenges have you spoken to her about
what that was like to had the two men in
her life dealing with cancer at the very
same time I don't know a stronger woman
in the history of the world she was so
brave she put on her game face at a time
when she probably you know really just
wanted to probably go in a room and hide
Rob found new meaning through his work
with smack in the aftermath of all that
you know thank God I was I was okay so I
had that moment where I was able to use
smack to get through difficult time so
you want to start smack at your school
now nearly 20 years later we started a
board of directors based on that
original crew of people and the people
who who were part of it from the
beginning and started to dream again
about what it could be this is that
dream becoming reality at the launch of
the national nonprofit Rene Ramos leads
the first New York Chapter of smack in
his Bronx High School this program is a
lot tuned on my grandfather died because
of cancer we actually have a few
students who lost their parents because
of cancer and you know being there to
help them support them
it's just feels amazing the group of
friends eventually ended up backward all
began but this time with a new
generation of future smack leaders there
are now 18 smack chapters across the
Northeast the organization has raised
more than two million dollar the fight
against cats after those guys
immediately please tell me still a lot
of you go wait for it it was so sweet
that he was live and then about his dad
that's sweet then about his mom that's
another layer and now it's a nationwide
thing and he's cute too
yeah there's always nice
great story and so jhin's first piece
yeah these things really matter it
reminds me if somebody reported on with
what to watch that the the cancer deaths
are actually falling in the US for the
first time in a long time and I'm sure
that's important to efforts like this
Rob's whole you know he wants people to
understand that you're not alone there
are people going through this and there
are resources well in it well and as
he's you know it's very when you're in
high school or college it's really
embarrassing it's tough act about and to
get that kind of support so huge glad
thanks
you